Oh
mr. Ben burns here and it is time for
another web design process video yes
today we're talking about wire framing a
high fidelity wire frame in Adobe XD
let's get into it
[Music]
last time I walked you guys through my
process of sketching out a low fidelity
wire frame which included a really basic
UX design process for a single page you
see we are completely redesigning the
landing pages the download pages on our
website in case you missed it here it is
again in 30 seconds first write down
responses to 4 prompts these prompts are
our goals for the page the user's goals
for the page the questions that the user
is going to need answers to in order to
accomplish the goal and the emotions
that we want to invoke step 2 start
sketching use consistent symbol to
represent different content types
step 3 look for that intersecting goal
they both you and the user shares and
start there step 4
sketch out the remaining content that
addresses all the other goals and
questions that's it guys that's a low
fidelity wireframe the whole goal for a
low fidelity sketch is to identify the
outline of the content it's to establish
the way that you want to structure the
information on the page now that we've
established that outline we're gonna
bring it into the computer for a high
fidelity wireframe now it's tempting
it's so tempting to jump right in to
visual design I like to hit pause here
and do a more accurate wireframe in the
end it makes the visual design process
so much easier let's get into designing
this high fidelity wireframe in Adobe XD
step 1 set up your workspace let's go
ahead and open up Adobe XD now this
video is not sponsored by Adobe I just
felt like using XD for the project but
hey Adobe listen they do have wireframe
kits out there that allow you to pull
components and arrange them according to
your wireframe but what I find is that
the the kits impact the visual design at
a later stage which is not good I prefer
to start with a clean art board
and to design from scratch that way it
allows that creative thinking to flow I
typically start with a desktop artboard
I know I know mobile first and all that
just go ahead and build and use a layout
grid I like setting up a twelve column
grid with a maximum grid width of 1440
pixels that's 1440 pixels
once your artboards and grids are set up
take a photo of your sketch upload it
and then put it on an extra artboard in
XD that makes it really easy for you to
reference it often step to block out
your sketch get a digital version of the
sketch as you drew it that way you'll
have all the components on the artboard
to move around later use shades of a
single color like gray or blue to keep
things simple and then use the same
symbols for images and videos that you
sketched indicate what content belongs
where using your headers estimate the
body copy length using placeholder text
and I use great xD plug-in called the
Florham Epsom by Pablo Claw chica that
makes this really really easy just I
just hit command option L and then click
the button and it fills that text space
once you're done
duplicate your artboard step 3 bring in
actual copy you want to start working
with actual copy actual text words even
if it's a first draft what so many
people don't realize is that writing
makes up so much of that positive user
experience so you want to bring in that
copy at a very very early phase trying
to move into visual design before
actually having copied is an uphill
battle I like to think of UX design as a
ping-pong match between our writer and a
designer there's so many of our other
visual things that we create are based
on the actual content the copy of the
page which is why you want to bring that
in at an early phase if you're a
designer and a writer UX design has a
very special place for you call me
working with actual copy can help avoid
bumps in the road later on like having
header that's too long and having to go
to two lines when you weren't prepared
for it to go to two lines or that
horrible feeling when you filled out a
whole pay
full of body text that in the end is it
really necessary and so now you got to
figure out what to do with that space
working with content from the beginning
helps avoid that kind of stuff
step four quality check so before this
point we haven't really changed much
about our original sketch that's about
to change
now it's time to start making tweaks and
I like to ask myself four different
question number one are there too few or
too many visuals I realized that the
user wouldn't actually see a visual of
the download and so way too far down on
the page so I switched some things up
move the header around and I got that
visual right up top
number two does the copy reveal any
missed opportunities my original plan
for that last call to action the last
button at the bottom of the page was
that it would scroll the page back up to
the top of the form but reading the
heading text made me realize that a
second form would probably be more
effective as it would shorten the user
journey by a click and we're always
looking to make that journey short and
delightful so I added that second form
to the bottom number three does the page
flow for the user sometimes it takes a
little context to see the content that's
out of order
the what's inside section seemed really
out of place especially after I put the
why section copy in and so I went ahead
and removed that altogether number four
can the basic composition be improved
the first one was fine but trying to use
the grid in a new way it really made the
composition so much more interesting I
am so happy at our progress so far this
is where we net it out
[Music]
we are now ready to start moving into
visual design I am so pumped for this
guys cannot wait to get this UI put
together
so just to recap our four steps number
one set up your workspace number two
lock out your sketch number three bring
an actual copy at number four do a
quality check and ask yourself those
four questions that's it that's all it
takes to build a high fidelity wireframe
so here's my question for you guys I
want to know what you want a deeper dive
in I didn't really cover any of the
Adobe specific keyboard shortcuts so if
you want to learn something specific let
me know in the comment section below as
always guys I want you to go out there
and crush it you've got this like
subscribe we love you we'll see you next
time
[Music]
hey guys mr. Ben burns here and I am
here we are covering how to hey guys mr.
Ben burns here hey guys mr. Ben burns
here why can't I say that what's up guys
yo its mr. Ben burn let's get into it